[Music]
you got to be
a certain type of person to get into
flying without an engine
the fact that we're able to leave the
ground leave everything behind
fly through the skies on nylon and
strains is exceptional
[Music]
the rat race is a seven day long
paragliding competition with 200
participants that also serves as the u.s
national paragliding championship
[Music]
my name is nick griese i'm a
professional paraglider pilot
a paraglider race is very similar to a
sailboat race
they race around buoys we raise around
several different gps coordinates that
we have to hit along the way
each morning the racecourse is
determined by the weather for that day
and a course typically ranges from 40 to
70 miles long
the first person to finish the course
every day gets a thousand points if
someone's five seconds back they get
9.95 and so on and so forth
and then at seven days you add up all
your scores together and whoever has the
most points wins
[Music]
i grew up in long island in a suburb
close to new york city
i went to beloit college in wisconsin
and after that i returned to manhattan
to take a job at a pr firm
my second day of work was september 11
2001. so i was walking to work and i saw
the first plane hit the world trade
center from the street
i don't know if that played a a
significant role but it played some role
in in me deciding that i needed to do
something
sooner than later if i wasn't completely
satisfied with what i was doing
so i sold all my possessions i lived out
of my car
all i did was fly
i've dedicated my life since 2001 to
flying paragliders for many years i've
been one of the top pilots in the u.s
and that to me is a sign of success
watching the start of a paragliding race
is a sight to behold
a hundred pilots launching off a hill
and then getting up into the starting
paddock which is what we call a gaggle
the start it can be a chaotic experience
of people that are trying to get to the
top so that they're in the best position
so everybody jockeying for position
once that starts it's just a glorious
experience of you know rallying through
mountain ranges for a whole day with
your
friends after seven days you're pretty
exhausted but you know that's also the
the real joy in doing any kind of
endurance event
just like with anything whether you're
trading stocks or
riding bikes or flying paragliders
you're
always trying to make progress and
increase your ability to succeed
and you know paraglide competition is a
beautiful example of pitting your skills
not only against your competitors but
against the elements
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cerro blanco is the biggest sand dune in
the world i had no idea people could ski
in a place like this
once you're at the top you have about
four thousand feet a vertical drop until
you get to the bottom
i will remember that moment for the rest
of my life
[Music]
my name is emma dalstrom i'm from sweden
and i'm a professional free skier
i'm yes presader i'm also a professional
free skier we're both on the swedish
national team
we travel all over the world to ski but
we usually go to the mountains where
it's cold and snowy
when we got to peru we started in a
small oasis called wakachina
you would look around and all you could
see is desert
[Music]
[Applause]
i was really nervous for my first round
in the sand because obviously it's not
snow
it felt sticky in the beginning but when
you got some speed it felt pretty
similar to snow actually
[Music]
it felt pretty cool to ski in shorts and
a shirt
[Applause]
we stayed there for about three days and
did some rails and jumps
and then we headed out to cerro blanco
which is basically one big mountain of
just sand
once we were at the base of cerro blanco
we hiked with all our gear for about
three or four hours
by the time we got to the top it was
completely dark
that next morning when we first saw the
view
that was magic
i watched the sun come out over the
mountains
and then we just dropped in
[Music]
it was such a crazy feeling and i was
smiling the whole way down
[Music]
when you're looking out for a platform
usually it's just water everywhere which
makes you feel really really tiny
jumping into this
giant ocean
i'm rachelle simpson
and i'm a world champion cliff driver
[Applause]
it's very similar to olympic diving the
only difference is at the end we're
going to land on our feet
as i climb up on the platform you hear
the wind blowing in your ears
sometimes there's seagulls zooming
around my head
i hear the announcer call my name
it's kind of like i'm going into this
hallway and the sound slowly cutting out
because that's when i'm going into focus
that's when i set my feet and then my
arms go up
i count to three
and go
your body's on autopilot and your brain
is just sitting back watching front
somersault twist second somersault right
position half twist
[Music]
when you hit the water at first you
don't notice anything and then it starts
all coming back you create bubbles
underneath the surface and you feel
those bubbles pushing you back up to the
surface quite a cool feeling actually
[Music]
when you come up take a breath of air
and the rush of adrenaline it's like
you've been holding it off
and not even breathing until you hit
that water
[Applause]
each time i enter the water it's another
successful moment of convincing my brain
to do something i'm scared of but each
time i get a sense of empowerment when i
overcome it
i love it
[Applause]
[Music]
once you start climbing then the biggest
hazard is avoiding all those big icicles
they are huge like the size of a family
car
those daggers are really not attached
that well to the rock and sometimes it
takes just a small kick and they
just collapse and fall down
[Music]
my name is clement premerl
i'm an ice climber and adventurer
my climbing has taken me to so many
different places all over the world
then hong kong falls came into the radar
and it just changed everything i mean
it's the steepest ice you can find
anywhere
once you're there and you're walking
towards the ice fall
you just get this feeling how big it is
i mean it's huge and it's steep
to have overhanging eyes it's really
rare
usually ice climbs are formed vertically
we didn't see overhanging eyes before
hancon falls
i do believe
life starts when you step out of the
comfort zone climbing forces you to go
outside of your comfort zone it forces
you
to look out for this fragile line
between
having good time and not risking too
much
fear is present a lot but
once i'm there and once i start to work
on the route the fair just goes away
there's no more fear it's just about
climbing and having good times
[Music]
when you highline often you really learn
to train your fear like a muscle
sometimes the height isn't the scariest
part sometimes it's the exposure which
is how much space you can perceive
around you
[Music]
my name is faith dickey and i'm a
professional slackliner
[Music]
so slacklining is the umbrella term for
all the different facets of walking on a
flat woven band
one of these facets is high lining which
is walking a slack line high off the
ground
one of the best ways to train for high
lining is setting up slack lines over
water
when the current is passing underneath
you you automatically start to fall that
same direction and it's almost like
you're not in control of your body
and that's great practice for highlining
because in highlining when you're
dealing with all the fear and adrenaline
oftentimes it feels like you're not in
control of your own body either
[Music]
shamany is a town in the alps of france
and it's one of the places that really
drives me in highlining what's different
about highlining in the alps is that the
whole experience is more intense
being that high off the ground you look
at the valley below and the houses are
just tiny specks they look like toys
it's unbelievable
one of the highlines that i walked
recently in shamany was on aguil du midi
and when we reached the top it was a
totally clear blue sky and we were
surrounded by peaks but during the
process of rigging the clouds started to
roll in
it was like an acid trip walking the
line
i was out there in space and exposure
trying to balance and the line was
swinging beneath me meanwhile these huge
white clouds were passing and the line
would disappear the anchor would
disappear and then it would reappear
and there was no way to control it i
just had to hang on
yes
the beauty of the mountains is awesome
and yet it is a landscape that demands
focus and respect
alpine highlining is the purest form of
the sport i can think of
[Music]
you